it's called i tried to change you don't
have to because he like
here's where i thought that you know
what let me do things that men do so i'm
gonna go through my man things then
oh let me act like i got it all together
and i'm rich
and i like fake it till i make it that
new make it then
i got to the point where i thought i was
going to be a rapper i had my i was like
missy elliot 2.0 i said okay let me do
the rapper fate i was the worst rapper
ever oh i couldn't keep a rhyme
then i thought i was gonna be the sexy
siren the plus-size sexy girl
that show didn't work then i said let me
go and be a televangelist
so i was gonna be a preacher
that oh i was forgetting the scriptures
and stuff it was
bad so you know what i don't been
through it all
so it's like yeah you know it's it's
it's an interesting story comedian and
the real co-host lonnie love covers it
all in her new memoir i tried to change
so you don't have to
out now from growing up in the projects
to career risks and dating mishaps
that all led to her success today and
romance with actor james welsh
this is a blessing to me so i just want
to share it and inspire people
in a chapter called real talk lonnie
opens up about tamar braxton's firing
from the reel
in 2016 and the subsequent back and
forth drama that publicly played out
you decided to open up in your book
about your former co-host who you know
some things have played out very
publicly um and you didn't have to
include
your take on it what went into that
decision
because my my fans are nosy
i write a book and i don't talk about
that they were like wait
wait wait lonnie what what
wait what what so
no it was like no question my fans are
nosy
they want to know so i have to tell it
you
you wrote about how challenging it was
to deal with
the the trolls who wouldn't leave you
alone and things actually seemed to get
pretty scary when all of that was
playing out
um how hard was it for you to go back to
those memories and relive that
not very fun time i've always been a
strong person
and you know in in the book you you will
understand
you know why certain things were said
why certain things wasn't said
and hopefully this will give people um
another view when people work hard on
their character
it's important that you protect that
character and just because
you know people scream loud on online
or you know you get a bunch of people
ganging up and making assumptions that
doesn't mean that that's true
that does not mean that that's true and
it does not mean that you
don't have the opportunity to say what
you want to say about something
so i'm you know i used to be the person
that
you know what just it'll all blow over
but we live in an age now in social
media where you
it doesn't blow over it's there forever
there are things that
everyone on the show has said that you
know it's still living
i think there's nothing wrong with
fighting for your character and fighting
for your truth
i want to say to tell my brags that you
are still our sister
this is your thousandth episode your
1000th
episode celebration you toasted to tamar
and i thought that was a really
kind and classy move where does your
relationship with her stand today
uh i don't know
have you guys spoken enough well the
reason why the 1000th episode
it was important because she was part of
the thousand episodes
um we've reached out to her and we'll
keep on
trying to reach out to her but you know
people
my whole thing is this my character
has been attacked because there are
things out there that are just not true
um and you'll read about it in this book
that is
my truth but when your character is
attacked
you know it does bother people say oh
you're bothered yeah you're bothered
because you know you don't want people
thinking certain things about you
and it's very important that you that
you clear that
up because at one point i wasn't allowed
to talk
that's in the book too i was i wasn't
allowed to talk
so now i can talk and i think
that once everybody gets their side out
then you know but it's always been open
we've invited her onto the show and
things like that you know it is what it
is
what do you want people to know about
your truth
oh i just want people to know that i'm a
good person and i would never
i'm for all women i'm not jealous of any
woman
i try to support women i wouldn't be on
a show
that's called the real that's about
women supporting each other
you know people just don't even know how
you know
this these stories that come up about
the show
and who likes who and who don't like who
and
all of that it's just nonsense but
really it is about
us you know supporting women so we try
to make the best show
that supports women i think i got a bad
rap
and all the girls got a bad rap but it
was really mostly on me
because we're allowed to speak about and
when you're not allowed to speak about
it
that means only one side of the story is
out there
and then what happens is perception from
that one side becomes reality
and that's what hurts did you have to
get clearance from your producers at the
reel in order to include that in your
book
no i think that um
the reason why it wasn't a big deal to
the studio
is because the way it all played out
and if you go back and you look i think
that they realize that
maybe some mistakes were made that it
should have been handled differently
and so it is what it is like being like
maybe they should have let you speak
when it first happened
do you wish you had had that opportunity
of course maybe we wouldn't be you know
dealing with this now
i mean it's like been six years people
still send me stuff and still accuse me
and stuff
and i'm like seriously first of all if i
could have my own show
you would i would have my own show
especially because
you know we are in a a very limited
group of women
and we're talking about women of color
so they all read the same story so they
all thinking the same thing
they think that they they trying to be
like
but they all thinking the same thing so
it would have been nice at that time to
have been able to actually say something
but you know as you read in a book you
can see wasn't allowed to
is there any part of you that would want
to reach out to her
maybe have her as a guest on the reel
clear things up
we it was an invite and still nothing
what you see on the reel you try to
support everybody it's nothing it
we didn't have anything to do with it
when it comes to making decisions and
stuff that's a
you know that's a whole that's all above
my
pay grade but people want to believe
what they want to believe
and it's just i just wish we could have
done this differently i can't i don't
know how many times i have to say i
wish it would have been held differently
but it's nothing i can do and i feel bad
this is why when people say why you keep
talking about it it's because you feel
bad you feel bad that one
you blame for something you didn't do
and two somebody did lose a job
like that was it was embarrassing it was
hurtful it was confusing for all of us
but when you say that people still don't
believe it so
i have a set of fans that really want to
understand it
so i put it in a book if she sees this
interview is there a message that you'd
want to say
i just wish her the best i think she's a
powerhouse i think she's
you know no matter what you know
things happen but it's just time to just
really get together and she knows that
we're not
we're not mad at her we're not upset
it's just that we just want
you know we want to clear the record and
the only way you're going to clear the
record
is if one she says something or we all
meet
um and just have it publicly out there
how is it gonna take what is it gonna
take
i don't i'm here so i mean you know i
still have her number every now and then
i'll text her i don't get a response or
nothing
it's like there's nothing to hide from
it's just let's sit down and talk
it doesn't even have to happen with
cameras or anything like that
i just want her to know but you know
okay
i'm hoping during these crazy times that
maybe we see her as a guest
on the virtual version of the reel and
we can get some piece and make it just
water under the bridge
oh yeah well you know i just think it's
hard i think i know that it's very
hurtful
and i i get that but you know
things have been believe me we i tried
i've tried to to contact her and
and and actually have her come on and
talk
i wish this was done totally different
because
none of the girls should have been
blamed none of us did anything
it's just it's just it you look at other
talk show hosts they
they get canned and contracts end all
the times like
why you know for and people need to
understand too
this was the first show that was like
all
women of color and it really tarnished
the show
i believe it left a cloud of suspicion
on the show
and it was you know it took like a
couple of seasons
for us to get over that and it really it
wasn't the show wasn't meant for that
the show was really meant to uplift and
show diversity
amongst women my third book is going to
be all about
the talk show space because it's just
people just don't know